and what I see all over the place is
people who care about looking good while
doing evil it's the fake good guys right
it's the virtue signalers who pretend
they are good while doing all of the
wrong things Tesla currently sells two
twice as much uh in terms of electric
vehicles as the rest of electric car
vehicles in United States combined Tesla
has done more to help the environment
than uh all other companies
combined would be fair to say that
therefore as a leader of the company
I've done more for the environment than
everyone any single human on earth how
do you feel about
that how feel about that yeah no I'm I'm
asking you personally how you feel about
that because this goes we're talking
about power and influence and I'm saying
I'm saying what what I care about is the
the reality of goodness not the
perception of it and what I see all over
the place is people who care about
looking good while doing evil
them okay do you see how they could push
a good man into starting to seem like
he's the crazy guy now I don't think
he's the crazy guy I don't think you
think he's the crazy guy but you can see
it right here he is saying hey I've done
more for the environment he's not saying
it to Pat himself on the back what a
great line I believe in the reality of
goodness not the perception of goodness
that's what virtue signaling is Right
everyone virtue signals about how
wonderful they are and all the things
that they do and everyone else is bad
and they're so good here's a guy
actually doing good he has done good
with Tesla I can tell you this you know
we have two Teslas okay we have two
Teslas and even if Tesla was doing jack
for the environment the cars are
awesome everyone that gets in my car
that's never been in a Tesla is like
this is the coolest freaking thing ever
they drive beautifully they're the
safest car on the road everything else
putting aside any of the environmental
stuff he'd also like to make a buck
while doing some good for the world and
not only is he doing good for this world
he is literally trying to get it so that
there will be interplanetary life which
ultimately we will need because this
planet is most likely going to burn
right like that is sort of where it's
all heading and by the way it's not
going to burn because of climate change
it's going to be burning because of all
the lunatics who are gladly setting a
blaze all of the the goodness that
humans have worked on over thousands and
thousands of years so the reality of
goodness over the perception of goodness
dare I say there's a little bit this is
going to sound like really lofty lofty
but there's a little bit of like a Jesus
quality there right like there really is
he's trying to do good and what is the
system doing to him right Christmas is
coming that is kind of the story of
Jesus right here a good person in a bad
time is suddenly thought of as the bad
guy